[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is finally
the pixel 4. the most leaked phone in
history probably is finally revealed and
i feel personally attacked so the title
of this video is google and gaps so the
pixel 4 we already kind of knew almost
everything about it but now that it's
actually out it's been on stage and the
details have all sort of been filled in
it's kind of what we expected it's a
very google phone android 10 and the
google assistant and some new features
and all that
but also
there's some head scratching gaps some
things missing
with this phone
let's get into it so the design similar
to other pixels is definitely the tamest
part of this new phone it's not a flashy
design at all to the point where it's
kind of funny it's got this big forehead
it's bigger than the chin it doesn't
have the thinnest bezels it has a flat
display which i actually like and
there's three colors black
white and orange i like they're still
doing the colored power buttons so the
panda one has i'm calling it panda the
panda one has an orange power button and
the orange one here has this sort of
pink power button that's okay i wish it
was white and they all have a matte
black metal rail around the whole phone
around the top the sides the speakers at
the bottom and the usb type c port matte
black all the way around everything and
it's a nice weight of the whole phone
and i really like the soft touch matte
finish on the backs seems like 2019 has
really become the year of matte black
finishes except except for the fact that
the black phone is the only one that's
not matte finish so this orange one is
matte on the back the white one matte on
the back and the all black phone which
could have been matte black everything
is glossy for some reason so
i don't know i feel slighted but you can
see what i mean it's a pretty simple
design flat display instead of curved
over the edges a solid pair of speakers
with the second one being up in the
earpiece at the top and on the back you
of course have your camera square bump
the infamous design trend to 2019 but it
isn't triple cameras up here it's dual
cameras a flash and laser autofocus so
it's one standard camera
and one
telephoto a 2x telephoto so they didn't
include an ultra wide camera on the
pixel 4.
and i don't know i was kind of waiting
this was something we've been waiting
for for a long time to see finally
multiple cameras in a pixel they've
always done the best they could with
software with one camera but the one
thing you can't fake with software is an
ultra wide so now that every other phone
in this class has an ultrawide i was
pumped to see it i was excited to see
what they could do with an ultra wide
camera on the pixel and then they didn't
do it
that's a bummer i feel like it's
actually a bigger deal that they didn't
include it than if they had just put it
in anyway so you have a standard camera
and the 2x telephoto and this will be
better for some things like portrait
mode which now only works with the
telephoto you can't take wide portrait
photos anymore and the rest of
everything else with the normal camera
should still be fine i mean this is one
of those things i got a test of course
for the full review to see if it's
actually better than the legendary pixel
3 or if there are instances where maybe
just night mode is better or if astro
photography or those things they showed
on stage with the stars and the moon at
night look better but so far from what
i've seen it looks to be another great
smartphone camera you can follow me on
twitter if you want to see the sample
photos i post and of course that'll make
its way into the full review but yeah so
far so good so while wide angle can be
fun
we think telephoto is more important
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i definitely feel personally
attacked all right so why does the pixel
4 have such a big forehead it's bigger
than the chin it's like notable uh i
guess it's better than the bathtub notch
but what's the big deal here pixel 4 now
has an entire suite of front-facing
sensors up at the top including infrared
and radar which is new in smartphones to
do what they call the fastest facial
recognition unlocking in any smartphone
and they're so confident in it in fact
that they've gotten rid of any other
biometric authentication which means no
fingerprint reader anywhere else on this
phone not under the glass not on the
back just face unlock so this all falls
under motion sense parts of it seem
pretty cool
other parts of it
a little rough so when motion sense is
on it uses the radar to sense when
you're coming near the phone to pick it
up and then it preps the cameras and the
sensors to read your face and unlock it
immediately as you're picking the phone
up so i tried it out at the event i put
my face data in with the new ui for that
and gave it a shot and it worked pretty
well i picked up the phone from a flat
surface and it was on and unlocked by
the time i even got it up to my face and
i didn't even have to press the power
button so that is pretty cool i don't
really think anything about the actual
reading of your face is anything crazy
proprietary it's still infrared it still
works at a decent amount of angles but
it's using that radar to sense when
you're coming and picking up the phone
and turning it on early that's the cool
part
and then they use radar also to do a
couple of other
gesture based things and these are much
more
hit or miss
i actually like the one where you have a
timer or an alarm clock going off and
when it starts beeping as you reach for
the phone the radar sees your hand
coming and quiets down the alarm
and that's pretty cool then you can
swipe it away and it silences it now i
got the alarm quieting down as i reach
for the phone to work every single time
flawlessly but the whole swipe away
thing
that didn't always work for me every
time and this was a theme in general
with the whole swiping thing it's hard
to get it right which you know could be
rough in the morning if you're trying
not to hit things on your desk as you
swipe your nightstand over and over but
it's also supposed to work for accepting
or denying a call and moving forward or
backward in media and this was way
harder to get it to work than it should
be when you're in a place where swiping
over the phone is supported you see this
glowing happening at the top in the
notification bar
and you can see it move to the left or
right when it works and it recognizes
your hand movement but i honestly think
i got it to work like 10 of the times
that i actually tried to swipe it there
was no real feedback about what i was
doing wrong or how i could do it better
so this seems like something i'm
probably never going to use you might
remember lg did this too on their last
flagship with infrared but i gotta give
them credit because they actually had a
little visual on the screen of at least
how to do the weird hand gesture better
like get closer or get further up top
there's no such indicator on the pixel
so it's frustratingly difficult anyway
my favorite feature about the pixel 4
without a doubt easy
is a 90hz display
love that my first impression is it
looks great it's nice and smooth as
you'd expect from a high refresh rate
display and it's a high resolution too
it's 3200 by 1800 so my first
impressions of this oled are it's pretty
color accurate
sharp but not very bright i definitely
struggled outdoors to get bright enough
um but it that's going to be its
weakness we'll learn more about this as
i use the phone more for the review and
then the rest of the specs snapdragon
855 not a 55 plus
uh then you're looking at six gigs of
ram starting at 128 gigs of storage and
2800 or 3700 milliamp hour battery i
think that smaller battery might be
something to keep an eye on for the
pixel 4 especially with that 90 hertz
screen um but the bigger one which i'm
testing the xl 3700 milliamp hours seems
fine i will find out as i test the phone
but uh yeah that's something to keep an
eye on and then it's android 10. so
mostly what we've seen in android 10 is
the same as previous betas on other
phones uh there's the new face unlock ui
like i mentioned along with some camera
app improvements
an improvement to google assistant that
speeds it up even more and let's use it
hands-free more often and there's also
now a pretty sweet built-in voice memo
app that's actually impressive it now
transcribes everything you say in real
time on the device and records it all in
text as well so you can see it marking
down all your words as you speak and
then you can go back into search and use
the text to search for each word you say
and it'll show where in the voice memo
you said that word so that's pretty
impressive if i was a big voice memos
guy i'd be super into that so look a lot
of the stuff
it's better it's not drastically
impressive like nothing really wowed me
and maybe that's because everything
leaked like we saw everything that was
going to be coming so it's impossible to
get surprised by the event but yeah it's
felt like there were
some serious gaps too like okay the no
matte black version of the phone okay i
get it you want to mix it up have a
little glossy fingerprinty back with the
matte black
okay and then the specs are better and
you have extra ram but no snapdragon 855
plus
it's kind of sort of this weird time of
year where phones are starting to come
out now with the snapdragon 855 plus and
this phone for more money doesn't have
it so it's kind of tough and then the
lack of the ultrawide was really
that's tough like i was so looking
forward to having like what could they
do with an ultra wide pixel camera how
good could it be and now we don't have
that
and it seems like google might not even
really care
super much about that either there's no
2x button in the camera app
it's just kind of there i thought it
would be mandatory if you adopt this
whole square thing like you have to have
triple cameras we'll see i don't know
for 7.99 i think the pixel 4 that
smaller one that's gonna be a tough sell
because that's a hundred bucks more than
the iphone 11 and uh well that's just a
regular pixel four but for the xl that
starts at 8.99 i think that'll be more
compelling interesting buy and that's
the one i'm testing so that's one to
stay tuned for the full review of
but let me know what else you want to
see in the comment section below if you
have any concerns
battery life maybe the cameras maybe
there's video quality things you
definitely want to see in the review let
me know but no matter what you do make
sure you subscribe to be the first to
see that when it comes out
techtobra rolls on lots of stuff
happening this has been your first
impressions of the pixel 4. thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
you